1958 et winnie madikizela 21 ans
diplômés en travail social épouse nelson
mandela âgé de 40 ans cinq ans plus tard
les projecteurs se braquent sur le
couple nelson mandela militant
antiapartheid est arrêté et emprisonné
pour trahison
à cause de ses activités politiques
mounir est seule à la maison avec leurs
deux fillettes et se démène pour faire
libérer son mari mais les écueils sont
nombreux
elle est elle même détenue assigné à
résidence ciblé par des bombes
puis banni par le gouvernement de la
minorité blanche mais elles refusent de
courber l'échiné
winnie mandela devient ensuite une
figure de proue du congrès national
africain
mais rapidement cette figure de proue
devient une source d'embarras
winnie mandela encouragent la violence
pour lutter contre la ségrégation
raciale
elle est reconnue coupable de complicité
dans l'enlèvement d'un adolescent on
l'accuse de corruption et de mener une
vie luxueuse alors qu'elle prétend
défendre les pauvres et les tout de même
aux côtés de nelson mandela à sa sortie
de prison en 1991
le couple héroïque marchent main dans la
main le poing en l'air et l'image fait
le tour du monde nelson devient
président en 1994 et winnie fait son
entrée au gouvernement
les frasques de winnie et son infidélité
ont raison du couple mandela en 1996
c'est le divorce après 38 ans de vie
commune
le secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
guterres esch se rappelle tout de même
un puissant symbole de résistance
le président sud africain cyril
ramaphosa parle pour sa part d'une
championne de la justice et de l'égalité
à soweto où on se rassemble devant la
maison de winnie mandela pour lui rendre
hommage en chantant et en dansant
ces deux femmes deux femmes en lutte
pour reconnais fin sans ambages le grand
rôle que je jouais dans la lutte contre
l'apartheid et surtout pour avoir
soutenu son mari mais aussi on va
ajouter entre parenthèses oui mais
malgré la controverse entourant winnie
mandela s'est vraisemblablement éteinte
sans regret en entrevue il ya quelques
années elle disait qu'elle ne
s'excuserait jamais et que si elle
devait recommencer
elle ne changerait absolument rien ici
n'est tonnelier vraie radio canada
montréal